Film Courage: Is there an antagonist or a
dark side to romantic comedies?
Pamela Jaye Smith, Author: An antagonist or
a dark side?
I think in romantic comedies, the antagonist
is either within or usually just without,
but not big.
Okay, take three levels of opposition: there
is internal, and then there is those around
you (family, society, culture), and then on
bigger levels of stories: there’s opposition
from the big outside, you know bureaucracies,
aliens, tsunamis.
But in a romantic comedy you want an antagonist
in opposition just at those two levels (the
close to levels).
This is a small story.
We’re not taking on the world.
We’re not trying to throw kingdoms.
So your opposition can be another person or
a bunch of people (family, society, culture,
sometimes religion but usually not because
there can be problems in them trying to have
a comedy.
Trying to get into those deeper philosophical
questions .
But so often, the main antagonist is within
one’s own self.
Take for instance MY BEST FRIENDS’S WEDDING.
Julia Robert’s main antagonist was herself
and what she thought she should have and how
she thought it should be.
And that was enough opposition to carry that
whole film because there was no one else against
her.
Now the situation was against her because
the guy was engaged and he was getting married.
But nobody was coming against her in particular.
She was doing it all to herself.
In MY BIG FAT GREEK WEDDING, you had both
those levels.
The insecurity and the family saying “No!
You’ve got to marry a nice Greek boy and
be Greek-like…you’re a Greek person.
Be a Greek person!”
So two levels for antagonist in opposition
in a romantic comedy.
Film Courage: I know you said earlier that
before starting this book, you weren’t a
huge fan of romantic comedies but what film
did you actually enjoy of this genre?
Pamela Jaye Smith: Well…I did have my favorites
already and certainly LOVE ACTUALLY is my
favorite because it’s got so many different
love stories in it of so many different types
and it’s so well-crafted.
Every writer should watch and deconstruct
LOVE ACTUALLY to see how you can create and
sustain character arcs (many of them) over
the course of a film and have what…7, 8,
10 storylines going on?
And they all work together, they are all interconnected.
And it’s brilliant, it’s brilliant writing
and filmmaking.
And the stories and the characters are so
endearing.
So LOVE ACTUALLY…I do like DOWN WITH LOVE
and MAMMA MIA because it’s so much fun to
sing to!
Seriously, can you watch MAMMA MIA and not
sing?
No you can’t!